now that you've learned how to
initialize an empty git repository let's
talk about how to add changes to a
repository in my recipes directory I
have the three files cake recipe txt
frosting recipe txt and chili recipe dot
txt on my hard drive which is called my
working directory I also have an empty
git repository that I just created
now I'd like to add a commit to this
repository now you might think I could
just run git commit to create a snapshot
of the current state of my files however
get allows you a bit more control than
this recall that it's a good idea to
keep commits small with one commits per
logical change it makes it easier for
you to do this by allowing you to
specify exactly what changes should be
committed to accomplish this it uses an
intermediate area called the staging
area you can add files one at a time to
the staging area for example first time
I add the cake recipe and then the
frosting recipe then when I'm ready to
commit git bundles the entire contents
of the staging area into a single commit
and adds that to the repository
let's see how this works on the command
line to remember what I've added so far
I'll use git status and I see that I
still need to make my initial commit and
my three files are still on tracked now
the command to add files to the staging
area is called git add first I'll add
the file cake recipe dot txt and then
I'll add the file frosting recipe dot
txt since I think it makes sense to put
the cake and the frosting recipes in the
same commits now I'll run get status
again and I can see that these files
show up as new files under changes to be
committed
this is gets way of saying that they
have been added to the staging area
since if I created a commit now these
files would be included now go ahead and
use git add to add whatever files from
your reflections repository you would
like to put in your first commit which
file or files will you add will you add
both files in one commit or will you use
separate commits for each file and why
write your answer in this box after your
staging area contains the changes you
want in your first commit run git status
and paste the output in this box